[Musica]
bene veramente un onore essere qui a
cinquanta chilometri da dove sono andato
a scuola e al 100 km avevo fatto è dice
internazionale però oggi voglio battere
a posto la città dove vivo e lavoro
adesso è alta da questa immagine di
vostro perché racconta molto di questa
città da un lato del fiume
abbiamo la zona più ricca dei migliori
ospedali al mondo e dall'altro lato del
fiume abbiamo la più grande
concentrazione di start up di lancio
scapito del mondo di azienda
farmaceutica mondo per cui in un
chilometro quadro potete immaginarvi
tipo di personaggi e di lavoro che che
uno può frequentare lavorando di hai la
sensazione di assen a macchina del tempo
di poter vedere quello che succederà tra
5 10 anni nel mondo del pane occupa il
mondo della salute e per noi che
abitiamo lì è facile immaginare un
futuro senza più malattie e non lo dico
come sogno lontano tra cent'anni vi dico
che in base a tutto quello che vedo che
succede intorno a me veramente possa
immaginare che tra dieci quindici venti
anni tutte le malattie siano morire
curabile cene avvenendo qui in aria
c'era cantone un paziente di alzheimer
molto avanzato come io e una settimana
pal è un'azienda in cui stiamo parlando
di circa 12 storici di studi clinici che
sono stati avviati e da cui aveva farmi
per dati per darmi dire però poi tornare
un po indietro e tornare al 99 il natale
non so se ricordate quelli di voi che
molti di voi cosa indica i nati per 90
noi proprio sito matrix e mano si
giocava gameboy uscito star wars giusto
per dargli insomma un'idea una ventina
d'anni fa e 99 euro a cambridge nel
regno unito è avuto il grandissimo onore
di partecipare e non si torni sita a
quello che poi diventò il progetto
genoma umano
un progetto che facciamo ha marcato la
storia della scienza e qui abbiamo
scoperto e ogni lettera del dna che sta
in ognuno di noi e tra l'altro vi
ricordo anche il 99 per cento di nablus
pal
crediamoci troppo intelligenti e
l'abbiamo scritto questo alfabeto
abbiamo lavorato tutti insieme tra stati
uniti giappone ogni terza un progetto
collaborativo incredibile che si è
concluso con la stretta di mano fra moso
per tra clinton e blair e rendere questo
patrimonio pubblico perché era stato
lanciato anche un progetto per renderlo
privato che poi in realtà da più grande
stimolo progetto al progetto pubblico
finito questo progetto ci siamo resi
conto che avevamo creato una maialata
incredibile è che veramente c'è la
moltissima complessità
dovevamo capire questa complessità dal
amori sodo la devono capire come come
articolare tutto questo mondo didattiche
avevamo creato e tant'è che in dieci
anni dopo nella seduta con una lista
dell'economist stavano facendo un pezzo
insieme ad altre persone che hanno
lavorato romano che non era molto felice
era del blooming price of human genetics
all'idea avete fatto tutto questo papa
di lavoro avete speso miliardi e non
vediamo risultato non vediamo pazienti
osservati da questa sequenza del genoma
come mai
perché perché non ci ha dato nessun
nessun risultato tangibile come sempre
nella ricerca ci vuole tempo ci vuole
tempo e specialmente in questo caso in
cui appunto stava nascendo tutto sta
nascendo linux da una sceglierlo persone
stava nascendo la capacità
computazionale cloud tutto quello che
oggi diamo per scontato che si permette
di analizzare per questi dati e
soprattutto quello che avevamo capire
dal per il rapporto tra causa effetto
vedete spesso nei giornali la
correlazione tra quante ne rimangi la
possibilità di una malattia quindi sono
correlazioni ci dicono qual è la causa
mi devono capire causa ed effetto
e forse l'argomento diciamo nel quale la
causa ed effetto sono più palesi sono le
malattie rare e io ho dedicato vari anni
che con de rosa raffaele quando poi sono
uscite tutte le tecnologie che sono
permesse in sequenza dei genomi in una
giornata di bambini affetti da malattie
rare per capire queste malattie e questo
è un bambino modo viene chiamata un giro
moda perché non ha un sistema
immunitario e e quindi tendenzialmente
delle vivere in una bolla ma poi
purtroppo entro tot anni qualcosa in
qualche momento negli anni entra e
questi bambini l'anno sistam immunitario
vere diciamo che ha un'aspettativa di
vita è molto molto breve aiuto non vuole
lavorare come ragazza dal caro luigi
naldini tutto il team telethon che
quando gli stati uniti avevano messo
grazie a bush hanno fatto le leggi che
proibì ma anche lavorare quelle cellule
staminali brevi vano saranno sei le cose
noi abbiamo riportato dopo hanno
riportato tutto questo talento in italia
per fare terapia genica cioè trovare i
modi di risolvere queste queste malattie
e siamo stati il primo cento e un mondo
è arrivato tutti di cantare l'ha fatto
una paura ci pensa farmaceutiche ha
commercializzato la cura per questa
materia per l'importante sapeva parola
cura cioè non è la pillolina che forse
ti fa stare un po meglio i maledetti tna
e colpito errori catinali questi bambini
a questi nomi fa
una vita normale purtroppo ci sono
ancora 7 mila malattie che dobbiamo lo
diciamo
guadando per almeno è un inizio
come è stato detto poi mi sono spostato
a dana farber crisi che è uno dei centri
tumorali che stalli auto money più
grandi al mondo
la cosa che voglio sottolineare perché è
veramente importante da capire che a
dana farber benessere centro piazzato al
mondo la routine è la ricerca cioè sono
900 studi clinici all'anno i 90 per
cento dei bambini sono in uno studio
clinico di ricerca questo è
importantissimo perché noi pensiamo
ancora diciamo alla l'appunto alla
scatoletta con le pillole e dentro che
viene commercializzata eccetera eccetera
ma le teste dei sas costantino maniera
talmente veloce il nostro campo che
veramente l'unico modo di veicolare il
più persone possibile fare ricerca
so che la parte delle persone e abbiamo
tecnologie incredibile abbiamo terapia
genica che permette ormai di fare
l'editing quindi dal cambiamento di ogni
lettura del genoma in poche ore e
abbiamo una decisione digitalizzazione
dei dati che che fa spavento e quindi è
veramente pensabile che si possa si
possono curare in moltissime lattiera a
breve per la cosa rimane rimane in
questo 90210 per chi vedeva da fare
televisiva e la zip cosa no lino già un
po niente
gli stati uniti vedi la metto qui per
dire che purtroppo il codice postale
al giorno d'oggi è ancora imprenditore
principale dei di come sarà la nostra
salute
batte tutti gli altri fatto se siamo
uomini da un anziano g il codice postale
dice quale sarà la vostra salute perché
perché dice quanto siete vicini a un
centro di eccellenza di edifici quanto
siete educato in
in materia di salute quanto minuti the
bene ci si va per ignoranza e la povertà
estrema alla persona anche alla fortuna
di abitare a due passi da un centro di
eccellenza con in ogni sicule quindi
questo questo e per noi il problema
principale non è affatto sei veramente
riusciremo a prevenire e curare sposate
tutte le malattie al mondo ma quando ci
riusciremo chi ne beneficerà
e come secondo me le soluzioni sono
molteplici ma tutte battono dalla
prospettiva di essere globali il poter
ragionare in maniera globale si sposti
brangi salute non a livello locale
nazionale ed i singoli e di singoli
centri e che ci saranno vari temi che
verranno affrontati la prima io la
chiamo bio logistica cioè il fatto che
tantissimi di queste cure avanzate poi
che farò vedere minutolo cosa intendo
hanno bisogno di spostare materiale cioè
dna sangue cellule cioè stanno
diventando molto sofisticate non basta
più e la pillolina la seconda della
portabilità digitale cioè pensate a un
drop box per la salute è un posto dove
io a precedere dove sono stato quando
con chi eccetera
tutti i dati sono lì e sono a
disposizioni di tipo ne può fare del
bene è traccia d'apprendimento in tempo
reale e qui paragone che mi viene in
mente tesla perché è uno dei delle poche
aziende che fa ridere il light lunch e
dove ogni macchina sta imparando dalle
altre macchine quindi con questi vedete
questi diciamo queste paragoni
e questi sono metodi tecniche che
dovremo affrontare per veramente portare
la salute a tutti perché appunto stiamo
andando da queste di queste pillole
scatolette facilmente dispensabili e
vendibili a tutte queste cose qui che
non ho tempo di spiegare ma che sono
complicatissimi facile in tumorale hanno
bisogno di uno scambio incredibile di
informazioni di cellule di denari
sequenza minuto didattici la terapia
genica lo stesso dei cult i suns che
sono due cellule
che sono adesso usate per fare in un
hotel vertirà piano il cancro stanno
inerente benefici enormi però sono
complicatissimi da gestire in cui
dovremo risolvere tutti tutti questi
problemi
poi adesso è stato detto nelle battute
precedenti e wall in questa azienda in
cui abbiamo male didattica termine
all'altro giorno stavo facendo un
progetto cosa stavamo guardando circa un
miliardo
l'impianto di farmaci redatti negli
stati uniti e questo è il bello della
famiglia li e petri che mi sento come la
mia è arrivata dal giocattolo che
aspettava da tempo che se possiamo
veramente guardare i dati di tantissimi
pazienti e questo ci permette di capire
il molto meglio cosa ha senso per il
singolo battendo il paradosso è che più
ne abbiamo ci possiamo capire per il
simbolo che cosa veramente possiamo fare
per quelle per quelle persone e tornando
a dai tag psiche però ci tengo a
rimarcare che è sempre l'esperienza
umana con intelligenza attività si
abbiano dei degli algoritmi intelligenza
artificiale fantastici mi sembra
esperienza mano il tocco mano dobbiamo
ricordarci che tutto ciò che facciamo
quei pazienti alla fine è un incontro di
due esseri umani e e quindi voglio
pensare un attimo non amate che ha una
bambina che ama affetta da una di queste
malattie rare che si si pone una domanda
che cosa devo fare oggi sentirete lastra
di violetta che sembra non siamo
conosciuti ri sembra sembra fatta
apposta per quello che voglio spiegare
con le mie immagini
io spero che per 10 20 anni questa nave
possa semplicemente dire a google
piuttosto che come ha detto nessun amp
che cosa questa questa bambina
e trovare la risposta anche se la
risposta magari non regge ed è un abito
al singapore ed e in un attimo si trova
la risposta per quella malattia si trova
a chiedere nel centro istituto che alla
cura e si fa arrivare direttamente a
casa con tutte le aziende che stanno
facendo una cosa è adesso nelle diverse
possibili
la cosa buffa è che io so che cosa ha
mangiato nemico a colazione singapore
stamattina grazie a facebook però questo
ancora non posso fare se ci pensate
incredibile usiamo la tecnologia per le
banalità ma non per le cause le sedi e
grazie a questo poter unire poter venire
appunto il bisogno la domanda e
l'offerta ma la domanda e l'offerta di
dibattere umana e che gli ottomani
quindi tornando all'inizio tornando a
massa ma anche il tempo che abbiamo
mosso dove possiamo vedere che cosa
succede al mentre 30 io vedo 0 pazienti
ma non nel senso che non ci siano
avevano senso che ci sarà per inizio nei
farmaci intelligenti e soprattutto
questo sistema di ricerca integrata e e
di unione che ci permetterà di far sì
che veramente ci siano 0 pazienti è però
dobbiamo assicurarci che sia per tutto
il pianeta non solo per boston e altre
città fortunata che se lo possano che se
lo passano tramite e in detto questo io
cercavo di raccontarvi la mia storia
dieci minuti di mezzo e perché di questa
antica yoga sapete che la posizione più
importante ultima cioè tutte quelle cose
in tortona te che si fanno yoga sono per
arrivare alla qualità mentale che era
necessaria quello che ho raccontato in
questi dieci minuti e quante volte mi
hanno detto no quante volte è diciamo no
ma come al posto fisso a university
caldo retropassaggio restare perché te
ne vai sei tornate riuscito a tornare in
italia si è riuscita ad avere un lavoro
ad atene e mandare a fare qualcos'altro
da sempre perché volevo imparato per
quindi ci tengo veramente moltissimo a
comunicarvi di non ascoltare mai chi mi
dice no che ne pensate che dieci anni fa
scusate sapevo di attacchi di panico
diagolo sapia e chi che poi nella stanza
mi conosce lo sa bene
essa sono pericoli della storia per cui
mi raccomanda non ascoltate my kitchen
ho ascoltate quello che avete dentro e
chiamate l'ex speaker che ho conosciuto
il recente drink che ha scritto un bel
libro ho fatto qualche volta italia
tremila chilometri per la cronica i
sogni delle persone che mi hanno colpito
la qualità dei sogni è che queste
persone avevano che qui in consultate
che sulla qualità dei vostri sogni come
li vedete alla qualità del posto sanno
scoprirete perché si rimanda
[Applauso]